[Music]
climate action is at the heart of
current eu concerns
but that's not new european countries
started acting
in the 70s to reduce pollution
improve natural and urban environments
and promote awareness of ecological
problems
the european commission introduced the
first environmental action program
in 1987 the single european act made
protecting health natural resources
and the environment an eu goal next came
the european environment agency in 1990
it informs people about and helps
monitor environmental action
in the eu environmental issues became a
fully integrated eu policy area with the
maastricht treaty in 1993
it also strengthened the european
parliament's role in developing
environment policy
but this was not enough to tackle
climate change
in 1999 the amsterdam treaty made
sustainable development a key objective
it became obligatory to integrate
environmental protection
into all eu policies like agriculture
transport
or regional policy so far so good
but the rollout of eu environment
policies was uneven across countries
so in 2001 parliament adopted minimum
standards for environmental inspections
punishing serious offences like illegal
emissions wildlife trade
or the dumping of waste and in 2015
the paris agreements were signed and
backed by the european parliament
it aims to keep the rising global
temperatures well below
2 degrees centigrade to try and limit
the effects of climate change
four years later the european parliament
took an historic stand
and the resolution is adopted
[Applause]
the commission responded presenting the
green deal
an ambitious road map to a climate
neutral europe
in 2020 the eu proposed a european
climate law
setting in stone the goal to reduce
greenhouse gases 55 percent by 2030
and the european climate law is indeed
the cornerstone of the european green
deal
as it enshrines into legislation
the union's objective to reach net zero
greenhouse gas emissions by 2050 at the
latest
2021-2030 the eighth environmental
action programme
will focus on accelerating the
transition to climate neutrality
to clean and efficient energies and to a
circular economy
[Music]
you